la technologie de pointe est au coeur de
l'exposition universelle qui a ouvert
ses portes au public ce matin
le thème est la sauvegarde de la nature
mais les manifestations se déroulent au
japon est le pays en profite pour
présenter ses dernières créations des
robots de plus en plus proche de l'homme
claude guaino jean christophe duclos les
véritables vedettes de l'exposition
universelle ce sont ces petits
d'humanoïdes musiciens ou danseurs pour
le japon l'expo de nagoya est une
formidable vitrine de ses technologies
de pointe
toyota sony hitachi mitsubishi honda
tous les grands industriels investissent
dans les robots intelligents destinés à
remplacer l'homme derrière ses airs de
cosmonautes à 6 mo est l'un des projets
les plus aboutis
c'est le premier robot qui peut marcher
véritablement courir monter les
escaliers reconnaître les personnes il
parle même plusieurs langues
à chaud on tient à 6 mo n'est pas un
jouet c'est un robot qui est destiné à
être utile dans la vie il ne peut pas
remplacer entièrement l'être humain mais
il peut effectuer certaines tâches à
leur place et nous ne sommes qu'au début
de nos recherches pas dans ce
laboratoire de l'université des sciences
de tokyo ces ingénieurs étudient le
système musculaire qu'il tente de
reproduire les mouvements du corps
déjà ils pensent à concevoir des
vêtements prothèse capables d'assister
les personnes ayant des difficultés
motrices mais leur grand projet c'est le
robot sapiens apparence humaine ou pour
le professeur kobayashi et ses étudiants
le robot est plus qu'un automate il doit
être doué d'une certaine forme
d'intelligence artificielle comprend ce
qu'on lui dit exprimer des émotions et
des sentiments
je suis en train de calculer la
résistance des muscles de la face
pour l'instant les mouvements du visage
sont encore trop faibles pour donner une
expression à ce visage
je pense que nous arriverons un jour à
faire un robot qui fonctionne comme un
être humain
depuis que nous travaillons sur le
silicone nous nous rapprochons de
l'aspect humain cela rendra des robots
plus facilement acceptable par les gens
l'aboutissement provisoire est encore
imparfait de ses recherches ses sayah
qui fait fonction d'hôtesses d'accueil à
l'université grâce à système de
reconnaissance vocale sayah parle et
renseigne les visiteurs
elle peut même sourire ou ceux montrés
étonnés